Right on the heels of releasing their new anthology album "Proof,"...
...the men of BTS have announced an indefinite hiatus.
The revelation came during an hour-long Festa dinner...
...in which the members sat around a table,...
...joking around while deciding what to drink,...
...reminiscing about their rocket ride to fame...
...and playfully teasing each other.
RM elaborated that after singles like "Dynamite" and "Permission to Dance,"...
...he lost the message he wanted to tell the world through BTS,...
...but J-Hope left us with all the hope for a new chapter with BTS.
He's the first soloist to break out during the hiatus.
He's performing at American festival Lollapalooza next month.